Я не вірю у вакцину, пігулки і тому подібне...
Звісно, ти зробиш. Це ж ти!
Робити щеплення чи ні? Ось у чому питання,
яке непокоїть нині багатьох,
коли от-от почнуть робити вакцини від COVID-19.
Тож я вирішила з’ясувати, чи готові люди на вулицях Берліна зробити щеплення...
- Так.
- Ні, я б не став.
- Я би поки що не хотіла.
- Так.
- Так-так!
- Я точно прищеплюся, хоча б заради відвідин батьків.
- Я не дозволю їм мене торкатися, чесно кажучи.
- Авжеж. Аби скоріше здолати пандемію і знову робити те, що нас радує.
- Якщо вакцину дозволять, то я теж довірятиму.
- Так, оскільки ризик від щеплення нижчий, ніж від зараження короною.
- Кілька місяців тому я б сказав "ні", але нині я вважаю,
якщо вже вакцина існує, тоді добре, що можна захистити себе й інших.
- Я зачекаю, доки стане ясно, на що вона здатна і які побічні дії.
Я також хотіла дізнатися, в чому полягають основні страхи людей щодо щеплення від COVID-19
- Побічні дії, які зараз ще ніхто не може передбачити.
- Бо не проводилось тривалих досліджень.
- Я боюсь того, що через 2 роки після щеплення раптом прокинуся і матиму пухлину.
- Бо я їм не довіряю.
- Тому що усе це - маячня. Йдеться лише про гроші.
Я поспілкувалася з експертами про вакцини, які вже поширюють
або є на завершальній стадії випробувань
Я запитала експертів, чи виправдані занепокоєння людей.
Почнемо з найпоширенішого занепокоєння, яке я чула на вулицях Берліна:
- Я боюся побічних ефектів.
Більшість компаній повідомили про дуже помірні побічні ефекти.
Найчастіше скаржилися на втому.
У ході випробувань ми не бачили жодних несприятливих випадків, безпосередньо пов'язаних із вакциною.
Кожна вакцина, зокрема й дозволена, має побічні ефекти.
Вакцини від COVID-19 - не виняток.
Але більшість побічних ефектів - дуже м’які.
Можливо, приблизно у третини людей підвищується температура.
Але це триває зазвичай лише кілька годин, а наступного дня все знову в порядку.
- Я стурбований тим, що не проводилось досліджень про довгострокові наслідки.
Більшість побічних ефектів з'являються відразу після вакцинації,
максимум протягом декількох годин або днів.
Дуже, дуже рідко буває щось пізніше.
Ймовірність чогось надзвичайного дуже і дуже низька. Такого як пухлини чи щось інше.
Тобто це просто неможливо з медичного погляду від цих вакцин.
І ці теорії насправді навіяні страхом і призначені для підбурювання страху.
Те, що ми знаємо про вакцини та загальну біологічну реакцію,
ґрунтується на десятиліттях досліджень.
І наскільки нам відомо, якщо щось і може статися,
як правило, відбувається протягом періоду клінічного дослідження.
Щоб зробити належну вакцину, потрібно сім років.
А тепер її, мовляв, зробили за три-чотири місяці.
Щось тут не так. Йдеться лише про гроші.
Я думаю, що концепція людей, які називають це поспіхом, є дуже хибною.
Як правило, виробництво вакцини може зайняти від 10 до 15 років від випробувань до затвердження.
Зазвичай це тому, що бракує грошей та зацікавленості,
а також, залежно від вакцини, недостатньо інвесторів.
Потрібно багато грошей, щоб завершити випробування, переходити від однієї фази до іншої.
І не завжди приділяється так багато уваги випробуванням, як зараз, коли ми маємо пандемію.
Завдяки всій цій увазі та грошам, зосередженим на COVID-19,
нам вдалося обійтися без втрат часу в процесі випробування вакцин.
Звичайно гроші відіграють роль.
Компанії хочуть заробляти і вже заробляють на цих вакцинах неймовірні суми -
з державного бюджету чи великих фондів, від приватних інвесторів.
Участь у виробництві вакцин дає величезний поштовх компаніям, які в це інвестують,
у них вливають дуже багато грошей.
Тому, звичайно, мова йде також і про гроші.
Ми давно вивчаємо ці вакцини та цей тип вакцин.
А також самі випробування вакцини, які хоча й технічно короткі, не були якимись спрощеними.
Розробку не намагались пришвидшити за рахунок зменшення безпеки та ефективності цих вакцин.
Я не думаю, що потрібно робити щеплення.
Тим, хто заразився "короною", щоб одужати, потрібно просто лишатися вдома.
Я не думаю, що це велика проблема. Це як грип.
Ще одна дуже прикра помилка - недооцінювати тяжкість цієї пандемії.
І я думаю, що це через те, що більшість здорових людей
можуть переносити інфекцію із порівняно м'якими наслідками.
Але існує багато людей, в яких ця хвороба залишає довгострокові негативні наслідки.
Нам відомо, що Covid-19 має серйозні довгострокові наслідки,
і ці ризики значно перевищують довгострокові ризики від самої вакцини.
Ми знаємо, що пацієнти з COVID-19 страждають від рубців на легенях,
від серцевих проблем, від неврологічних проблем,
і ці проблеми набагато важчі, ніж ті, що може спричинити будь-яка вакцина.
Люди мають зрозуміти, що коли ми робимо щеплення, це важливо не лише для нас самих.
Вакцинація є актом альтруїзму. Ми робимо щеплення і для себе.
Але також тому, що серед нашого населення є люди, яким не можна його робити.
Є люди з ослабленим імунітетом, люди немічні,
люди занадто молоді, люди занадто старі,
які з тих чи інших причин не можуть отримати деякі з цих вакцин.
Тому я вважаю, що ми повинні розглядати щеплення як акт співчуття до наших ближніх.
Ще до коронавірусної кризи страх перед вакцинами став глобальною проблемою.
. Минулого року Всесвітня організація охорони здоров'я фактично назвала це
однією з 10 найбільших світових загроз здоров’ю.
Одна з причин цього - стало більше дезінформації.
Один з міфів - що технологія, яка використовується для деяких вакцин проти COVID-19,
впливає на вашу ДНК.
Тож це поширена помилкова думка про вакцини з мРНК.
Матрична РНК абсолютно не може змінити вашу ДНК,
вона зовсім не так працює.
Все, що робить вакцина на базі мРНК - вона інформує ваш організм,
як виробити спайковий білок,
по суті, каже вашому організму, як його ідентифікувати.
І робить це без реплікації вірусу. Вона взагалі не взаємодіє з ДНК.
Біологічно неможливо, щоб вакцина щось зробила з вашим геномом
або мала згубний вплив на нього. Це немислимо.
Ще одна поширена теорія змови про те, що вакцина є начебто прикриттям для плану
імплантації людям крихітних мікросхем, і начебто за цим стоїть Білл Гейтс.
У тебе є чіп, який відстежує, де ти перебуваєш.
Ти прозорий і вже не маєш власної думки.
Це чергове поширене непорозуміння.
І воно базується на  одному факті, вирваному з контексту.
Насправді було повідомлено про наявність відстежувачів в упаковці ліків.
Вони - в упаковці, у зовнішньому флаконі, щоб відстежувати розповсюдження доз по всьому світу.
Але всередині мікросхем немає.
Це ж свого роду трекер поштової посилки для відстеження вашого пакету.
Мета цих чіпів - відстежувати доставку цих флаконів з ліками.
Але вони не в самій вакцині. Лише на пляшці.
Чому так багато дезінформації довкола вакцин від COVID-19?
В разі інфекційних захворювань майже автоматично стається інформаційна епідемія -
потік неперевіреної інформації та дезінформації.
Причому за будь-якого спалаху інфекційних захворювань.
Люди мають зараз справу з такою кількістю невідомого і не знають,
як відрізнити факти від вигадок.
Тому, мабуть, це природно, що люди часом
не розуміють наукову інформацію та не передають її коректним чином.
Отже, перш ніж поширювати інформацію, зробіть на секунду паузу
та переконайтеся, що вчиталися у кожне слово.
Перевірте, коли оприлюднили інформацію, хто і чому.
Це лише теорія? Чи вже проведені дослідження?
Чи є додаткові дані, щоб підкріпити вашу заяву?
Чи погоджуються з цим експерти?
Це допоможе вам відрізнити факти від міфів.